an invisible barrier protecting us from
the Sun Decades of damage from pollution
weakened the ozone layer but now thanks
to International action it's finally on
the mend the ozone layer is on track to
recover within four decades in a new
report a u.n-backed scientific panel
confirmed that the phase out of nearly
99 percent of banned ozone depleting
substances has succeeded in safeguarding
the ozone layer leading to notable
recovery of the ozone layer in the upper
Stratosphere and decreased human
exposure to harmful ultraviolet rays
from the Sun
ultraviolet radiation can cause skin
cancer and harm crops in marine life
the problem came with the development of
what's known as CFCs chemicals used in
hundreds of products from refrigerators
to Hairspray
but when these chemicals enter the
atmosphere they damage the ozone layer
an international treaty banned CFCs in
1987 but progress wasn't always smooth
in 2018 scientists detected a rise in
CFC emissions they were traced to
factories in China soon after emission
levels resumed their downward Trend the
predictions are promising but other
challenges remain I think that that's
also could be a role model also for for
when we tackle climate change but but
it's actually the problem with it was
quite restricted because there were some
substitutes available for this CFCs
which really destroyed this ozone layer
and nowadays we all work with the
substitutes and and for for the promise
with the the climate change is that CO2
cannot easily be substituted the final
holes in the ozone layer of the
Antarctic are said to be healed by 2066.
the rest of the world will be sooner
around 2040. activists hope this success
could prove a model for cooperation as
the world faces other challenges like
climate change
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera